accepteriez vous d'être pendant un temps
privé de votre télé est-ce que vous
pouvez vous passer de votre poste chéri
et bien sûr des vedettes qui vont dedans
privé de télé c'est l'expérience compte
accepter un certain nombre de ménages
français qui vivent à créteil pendant un
mois une équipe de télévision
jean-claude raspiengeas ce de télérama
et patrick volson ces deux hommes ont
filmé le résultat
pendant un mois
nous souhaiterions que vous nous confiez
votre récepteur de télévision
nous souhaiterions essayer de le voir de
quelle façon vous réorganiser la vie
familiale les loisirs les relations avec
les amis comment vous organisez votre
temps libre avec la disparition de la
télévision
nous souhaiterions vous filmer pendant
que vous faites autre chose que regarder
la télé lui disais simplement ce moment
il ya lille i à roland-garros à la
télévision et c'est assez ennuyeux pour
ceux qui aiment le sport et qui ne
peuvent pas y assister en direct c'est
vrai c'est une privation mais une
privation l'a vraiment
comment est venue cette idée diabolique
moi ce que je voulais savoir si vous
avez possibilité de contrôler la
tricherie pendant ils ont créé jose qui
vous donneront leur poste est-ce que
iront pas chez d'autres voisins
regardent si une saisie
voile alors je trouve que c'est plus
amusant s'il est au bout d'un moment
vous irez chez les voisins et de frais
aux choses avec les voisins plutôt que
de regarder la télé
seul problème ce sera peut-être la
présence des caméras la maison je ne
serai ce qui à part mais vu les gens qui
sont volontaires pour faire cette
expérience
[Musique]
je sais pas encore je peux faire
réfléchir j'estime qu'il faudrait avoir
la vie de mon conjoint pour tenter
l'expérience pour le moment je n'éprouve
pas le besoin de faire cette expérience
l'a pas fait ils peuvent pas si je vous
donne mon poste de téléviseurs mon poste
de télévision jeux souffrira beaucoup je
pense
à ce que les enfants lors de récré a2
pendant qu'on fait le dîner ça c'est
génial
mais moi je suis je suis volontaire très
volontaire d'une part
on est très intéressé je suis volontaire
parce que moi je suis de l'afrique et au
village a pas de télé j'ai envie de se
retrouver personnellement êtes-vous
décider tout seul pour votre famille
vous n'avez pas demandé non gd si c'est
un exemple
aussi seul ici pour pour prendre la
décision mais mon mari ne pouvait pas
être là et il voulait que participer
elle a l'expérience quand il saura ce
que c'est surtout à la veille de roland
garros ans qui comprendra mai
ouah ça m'arrange mais moi j'ai une
vidéothèque j'ai une vidéothèque qui à
tous les grands prix de 1981 et disons
que ça sera une condition c'est que vous
fournissiez des cassettes
est d'accord mais mais je commence à
monnayer voilà moi je veux bien que vous
l'appreniez gdo j'ai d'autres hobbies
oui vous faites quoi par exemple je fais
la couture way est ce que d'autres
volontaires alors faites votre
expérience au début j'étais pas très
tenté un parce qu'effectivement je suis
un fan de télévision mais je crois que
celui qui a réussi à me convaincre de
tenter l'expérience c'est mon fils c'est
lui qui me dit il faut laisser tomber on
va essayer on verra bien je crois que
pour ça on va le tenter
le lendemain matin nous prenons
possession de notre petit deux pièces un
coq et rez de chaussée avec vue
imprenable sur le quartier 35 familles
ont bien voulu se séparer de leur poste
il nous reste à aller les chercher nous
leur avons laissé le temps de réfléchir
et ça pourrait bien se retourner contre
nous on ne veut pas qu'on touche à mes
affaires je ne veux pas qu'on me prenne
je ne veux pas voir les huissiers chez
moi dont je n'ai parlé à mon mari m'a
dit qu'est ce que tu veux faire
on n'était pas spécialement emballé et
puis mon bon bah moi l'ont tué j'ai dit
bon mais quand on a une tous les postes
clés très bien la maison
alors s'il vous plaît vous nous avons
fait un petit peu plus
vous avez vu une dizaine de courageux
ont déjà pris la fuite enfin c'est pas
grave sur 900 familles 250 sont venus
hier soir 35 ont accepté 13 se sont
désistés reste 22 familles qui vont
faire l'expérience avec nous d'ailleurs
les voilà ils sont tous là sous notre
surveillance sous vos yeux pendant un
mois nous ne les lâcherons pas ils ne
pourront pas nous échapper pour
l'instant on dirait un échantillon
représentatif de la france des villes
nouvelles
regardez les bien ils ont encore le
sourire l'objectif
comme ils ont l'air sympa et déterminés
ils ont le droit ce soir de regarder le
match de foot à la télé un certain
juventus liverpool au stade du heysel
je suis beau ça bonsoir je m'en sortir
votre téléviseur eh bien il ya un
contretemps fâcheux pour vous c'est que
j'ai changé d'avis et je ne vous donne
plus mon poste de télévision à pourquoi
est ce que vous aviez pour nous oui mais
j'ai mes parents qui sont là pour le
week-end et ça m'ennuie un petit peu de
vous laisser dans la mesure où
savez ce que c'est
voilà on est venu vous prendre votre
téléviseur ou le confisquer pour un mois
vous êtes toujours d'accord tout le jure
je le prends aussi vous laisser partir
sans regret dit
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous laisser
partir au stationnement
l'atelier prend beaucoup de temps et qui
attire beaucoup de monde et beaucoup de
jeunes regardent la télé et puis j'ai
besoin de contacts hors de cause et de
parler sans la télé
[Applaudissements]
téléviseur ça tombe bien on va vous lui
enlevez d'accord
[Applaudissements]
paris c'est bien sûr maintenant oui à
plus impliqué quelque chose quand même
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
accepté c'est un peu un défi à moi même
parce que
je me suis aperçu de la télé était
devenu vraiment une habitude de la
lumière si vous voulez automatiquement
même quand je la regardais pas lorsqu'il
temps c'est tout ce qu'il valait mieux
enlever la télévision vous vous avez
aussitôt embrayé derrière oui on a
embrayé derrière pour la simple raison
qu'on en avait envie il peut depuis
assez longtemps
puisque
au moment où on s'est mariés pendant
l'heure de notre mariage on avait pas de
télévision s'était passé pendant un an
et demi à peu près et depuis l'idée nous
trottait en tête et on attendait le
déclic tu vois qu'il ya un deuxième
petit post vos pieds à quoi servait-il
celui là
essentiellement la télé du matin il
était branché à la salle de bain et en
faisant la toilette j'en profite
également lui c'est vrai droguée ou des
secteurs le matin jusqu'à une heure du
matin soit
est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez
tenir le coup un mois en france
et vous vous êtes touché pas serment
pourquoi vous vous doutez de toute façon
je crois qu'à on ira le voir chez
quelqu'un quand même vous avez triché je
croirais vous avez déjà pris vitry chez
elle moi j'ai pas prévu mois moi je
pense que oui y'a
et pourquoi vous serez chargé
je crois que ça doit être dur comme un
tout un mois sans terrain dans sa valise
et voilà nous avons ramassé 23 postes
finalement ça n'a pas été trop difficile
dans l'euphorie du moment tout s'est
très bien passé nos cobayes ne réalise
sûrement pas ce qui leur est arrivé la
télé est parti que vont ils faire
laissons-les s'habituer à ce nouvel état
le temps pour nous de visiter le
quartier il paraît que ça ressemble à
l'amérique
m
[Musique]
e
vous avez de mon téléviseur
j'ai changé d'avis mes parents sont
partis donc je n'ai plus de raison de
garder encore changer le plus
d'habitants est une fois de plus une
fois de plus martin devait d'être est
affirmatif la dernière fois donc le pas
d'autres solutions on peut être sûr que
votre femme et vos enfants sans déconner
mais aucun problème vous n'allez pas
revenir les chercher de matane parce
qu'ils ont contre nancy vous voyez mon
fils est arrivé aux lignes arrières on
ne sait pas on ne souhaite pas vous êtes
prête à dire et moi maintenant je tiens
moi sans problème bon écoute et mettez
votre téléviseur a été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis quatre jours nous ne savons plus
ce qui se passe les commerçants vont
peut-être nous renseigner au supermarché
c'est simple on n'a rien vu rien entendu
heureusement rien n'échappe aux
buralistes par contre encore une
personne qui sont télévision est
complètement désespéré on peut dire
désespérée le mot n'est pas trop fort
cindy très dire le peu de cafard
je pensais que vous voyez que la télé
n'étant pas là un jour il fait beaucoup
de choses et je m'aperçois que je ne
suis pas grand chose voyez hier soir
j'avais un peu de papier a cassé j'ai
d'aussi a menti je n'ai pas envie de le
faire alors que si la télé tu es là je
ne le ferai pas je le ferai quand même
ce classement voyez en regardant un peu
la télé 1 mais du fait qu'elle n'était
pas là je n'avais envie de rien faire je
voyais qu'une seule chose mon lit molly
et a ébauché pour ne plus penser à la
télé c'est surtout me coucher pour ne
plus y penser c'est comme si j'avais de
la famille beaucoup de parents chez moi
et sont partis tous ensemble et c'est ma
donner le cafard
celui là c'est le plus un taxi quai du
groupe hélie bel hassen il s'appelle il
a promis à sa femme et à ses enfants de
ne plus toucher à la télé mais nous
préférons le surveiller et nous n'avons
peut-être pas tort
en revenant du tri postal d'austerlitz
dominique race honneur en manque de télé
reste planté tous les soirs devant les
programmes de la ratp dont il est sans
savoir l'une des stars
ce soir j'ai pu rien faire et bien plus
mitigée par un affaire aujourd'hui
les parents le soir tu fais rien ban on
utilise les écoutent la radio et puis
moi je vais me coucher
quand vous rester chacun dans votre coin
les parents
restent ensemble
moi je reste dans ma chambre tout ça
alors toutes les charges ou pas la
donner
mes idées
j'avais des hommes c'est comme
ça qu'est ce que vous faites là ce soit
regardez n'ont pas pu résister c'est un
ami je crois que vous étiez privé de
télé oui mais c'est la seule fois où on
a craqué
c'est la première fois et la seule en
une semaine que vous avez vu germer de
la cia le faire craquer mais j'ai pas
voulu craquer devant quoi pour serge
gainsbourg vous n'avez pas très raide
radio alors j'avais écouté dernier vous
avez écouté tout le match à la radio rai
et vous aussi mais moi j'étais à côté
mais je lisais mont bouquet
vous avez réussi à tenir pendant tout le
match vous vous êtes pas dit mais enfin
ça me manque c'est dommage j'aurais bien
voulu le voir à la télé quand ça s'est
passé ben ça m'a rappelé d'abord quand
je les écoutais à la radio avant donc
c'était pareil et puis là-bas je
m'imaginais un pot de vin un téléviseur
quand même enfin ça m'a pas trop manqué
lampard allemand des finances mais vous
avez écouté attentivement une brèche
alimentaire attentivement et c'était
bien rester pas mal
aujourd'hui c'est pas la joie il pleut
il fait froid nous voulons terre aussi
doivent avoir le cafard passé
l'après-midi à regarder les goûts de
couler le long de leurs fenêtres
bernard vous ajouterez regarder la
finale de roland garros et doit aller
chez des amis la voie sinon ça n'a pas
été possible il a rencontré le voisin
qui lui a proposé sa télévision alors
les devants de postes
ses joueurs lui donc je vous conjure ça
va très bien vous allez bien conscience
tranquille
parce qu'on vient d'apprendre que nous
étions comme clichés moi oui vous ai
bien post la chaîne a oui mais juste
pour la finale de roland-garros avec lui
via ce poste
pour l'instant de regarder les chaînes à
la veste rouge 17e jouez pas le jeu sera
si je joue le jeu ça fait des jours que
j'ai pas de télévision si elle pour la
finale je ne regarde pas le jour noir
mais vous étiez engagé à pas avoir de
poste à vivre sans télévision sans
que je sois je les regardais chez welch
et des voisins entre me soit je n'ai pas
la possibilité ou kalta je la fais venir
à la maison pour un événement important
que celui-là non mais ça va pas on va
vous le prendre à vous le rende parce
que vous jouez pas dessus à neudorf ah
non on en discute mais vous ne prenez
pas comme ça avec à terme la scission de
la non non je suis pas du tout d'accord
je regarderai fin du tournoi et puis on
entre à la fin si vous voulez
c'est vraiment un après midi de chien
jeanne lui se tient encore le coup mais
c'est dur nous sentons qu'il va se
passer quelque chose nous avons même
engagé des paris entre nous elle va
craquer c'est sûr mais quand il nous
arrive même de penser que si nous
n'étions pas là ce serait déjà fait elle
nous a raconté tout à l'heure qu'elle se
promenait qu'elle faisait de la couture
pour tromper sa solitude
décidément ce dimanche pour y est
propice aux confidences
est-ce que vous avez compris pourquoi et
comment vous étiez arrivé un tel état
comme on y arrive ça je crois qu'on s'en
rend pas compte c'est un engrenage on
est pris en regard sur elles mêmes des
émissions qui n'ont aucun intérêt
on est là deux ans où on est passif je
crois que j'avais réfléchi un petit peu
je vais trouver une expression qu'il
m'avait plu c'était une c'est une
évasion passive et télé peut pas dire
que le samedi après-midi et des
émissions super intéressante
très passionnant et je vais vous n'aviez
l'énergie de vous relever aulas et ça
c'est exactement le mot que j'avais pas
une énergie là non
mais quand vous êtes arrivé certaines
fois c'est toute la journée de samedi en
pyjama
c'était maintenant je me rends compte je
me dis meetic ce que j'ai pu faire avant
c'était il est 8h30 a eu un bon film on
a ça on à s'installer pendant alors que
manon n'y a rien qui passe soudain qu'on
continue à discuter même si cela vers
9h30 alors on a plus d'un reportage ici
dans la région parisienne est bien parti
dans les villes nouvelles les gens ont
plus tendance à rester chez eux alors
que si j'étais un loader je pense que
j'aurais fait toutes choses dont je dis
pas que j'aurais pas regarder la télé
mais je pense que sur tous les week-ends
sortie aux champignons dans la nature
sans problème en france et sur laquelle
elles n'ont ils pas autant accaparé que
qu'ici argentin mais pourquoi n'y
avait-il pas la télé chez vous parce que
mon père a estimé que ça nous empêcher
d'étudier et quand vos copains vous
parlez de de télé comment vous
réagissiez
au début quand il parlait de choses puis
moi je jouais vraiment pas le rapport
avec ou de jeux ou de jeu vous jouez pas
de qui voulait parler quand il parle de
colombo schéma qui s'était lui parlait
de monique ce schéma les dégâts qui
parlait ça fait qu'il ya des souvenirs
que vous ne partagez pas ah ouais c'est
marrant d'ailleurs parce que quand on
envoie les séries télévisées qui tienne
ça j'ai vu le moins appuyé lui l'a pas
vu par exemple zorro être comme ça à lui
l'a jamais vu euros il a fait d'autres
choses que moi j'ai pas fait mais ton
taf et de la musique est appris la
guitare tu as fais plein de musique et
puis moi je n'ai pas pris un peu de
musique une chose que l'ami grèce et
quand on allait chez lui comme avait pas
de télévision son père sa mère sa soeur
lui rêve tous ensemble on discute on
passait des heures et des heures et des
heures à discuter raconte et on peut
raconter des trucs de l'épargné tout
comme ça c'était superbe moi j'adorais
ça il a parlé du moment où on leur a
offert la télévision ce genre de
discussion a pratiquement disparu
maintenant la télévision est en marche
quand on mangeait est en marche quand on
est là elle est toujours à la télévision
un bon bah c'est sûr que c'est parce que
ils ont princeville ont pratiquement pas
eu la télévision mme msss a changé c'est
certain ça change et d'ailleurs ça me
fait penser à quelque chose qu'on fait
je me disais que j'étais chez moi gamin
je me disais si bizarre mon père pour
lui c'était une personne
de l'ancienne génération c'est-à-dire
bangui faisait pas travaux ménagers il
avait toujours le besoin d'être dans son
jardin à l'eau c'est un tout petit la
parcelle de terrain là je venais mais
qu'est ce qui fait de la journée là bas
tous ses week-ends là bas et maintenant
que bon que si vous voulez j'ai pas de
télé et donc j'ai il a neigé pas de
moyen de me divertir à la maison je le
comprends très bien moi aussi les
problèmes besoin de toujours être dehors
notre seul moment de répit c'est l'après
midi tout est calme le quartier est
désert
tout ce travail nous prenons le ferais
nous parlons régulièrement de la télé
après tout nous n'en sommes pas privés
alors nous la regardons comme tout le
monde hier soir nous avons vu un film
anglais des duellistes c'est bien la
télé mais dès la sortie de l'école ça
recommence ils viennent nous raconter
leur vie c'est plus fort qu'eux ils
viennent même nous voir le soir quand on
est apte à pour les adultes ça va assez
bien pour les enfants ça va moins bien
su qu'à huit ans il supporte carrément
mal le mercredi après midi son télé
médicaux très content ça a été nul
je l'aurais
vu
ça nulle la bouche d'un enfant c'est
drap ou pas une ville loisy g1 profité
que ça va très bien et je vais regretter
je sors beaucoup enfin ça va quoi
jusqu'à présent ça ça se passe bien je
m'attendais à pire on a quand même
triché une fois mais pour l'émission de
gainsbourg on a regardé et entre-temps
moment on se rabat sur notre radio puis
on discute un peu plus ensemble aussi un
peu plus de rap pour
[Musique]
là je crois que suis en train de craquer
l'as
nancy
a développé un petit peu les relations
avec les voisins et c'est une bonne
chose
je pense que tu travailles beaucoup plus
oui j'ai de l'avancé sur mon travail
personnel à la maison c'est vrai sur le
travail professionnel aussi ouais c'est
une bonne chose
plusieurs fois je venais déjà pour
tours enfin ici pour essayer de
récupérer puis sont excités moche or je
repartais tout va bien
ça ne manque pas trop
il ya quelques émissions qui m'ont
manqué mais enfin bon je m'en suis passé
quand même j'ai pas triché j'ai pas été
voir chez des voisins on se retrouve on
est on est bien quoi vous faites comme
nous débrancher votre récepteur et vous
verrez c'est superbe et on est victimes
de provocations de la part de copains
qui nous téléphonent pour nous dire que
c'est bien ce qui est relaté les
français des films par exemple le
support duellistes l'autre soir hier
soir d'un coup de téléphone et copains
d'avant dire c'est bien la télé
à
la télé ce soir le jeu de la vérité sur
tf1 châteauvallon sur antenne 2 et petit
cresson sur fr3 nos volontaires n'ont
pas eu à choisir désormais ils sont
totalement disponible le cirque du
trottoir est bien tombé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
bonjour vous devez nous devons de
télérama d'antenne 2 mai qu'il n'y a
personne pour l'instant pour vous
réponds égale agents qui y est de nous
laisser un message après l'étonnant à
bientôt mairie
allô bonjour et c'est madame luce j'ai
craqué
on l'avait prévu jeanne luce a fini par
craquer la voir aussi radieuse avec son
poste dans les bras nous inquiète un peu
et si sa défaite devenait contagieuse et
s'ils se mettaient tous à en faire
autant
heureusement missoumi nous rassure
au moins on peut en être certain elle ne
viendra pas chercher son poste c'est la
plus dynamique du groupe la seule à
avoir tenté d'établir des relations avec
ses voisins des sénégalais par-ci
palabres par là elle fait vraiment
plaisir à voir mais si vous voulez une
seule faute ces trois là et ça peut
durer 1 3 et 2 être comme ça peut durer
une heure ça permet de pas là mais comme
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui exactement
mais aujourd'hui notre goût nous allons
quatre familles de mais ça sera 5 après
deux mais ça ça si c'est plus léger
avantage est qu on aura une
communication et
ses dénégations sac à merde parce qu'il
faut bien prendre le thé avec missoumi
mais pas question pour nous d'oublier
jeune luce qui fait le retour de sa télé
toute seule chez elle non j'ai voulu jeu
j'ai voulu me lancer un défi bon je n'ai
pas tué le coup mais tant pis
l'essentiel maintenant j'ai ma thierry
connais moins bien c'est fini vous me
reverrez plus même si vous recommencez 9
l'expérience
bon là je vais pouvoir retrouver tout
mon petit mot dans les visages connus
tous les voix notamment pour trouver une
autre en suisse et
c'est un peu de moi qui étais parti je
vous ai dit
c'est vraiment convaincre
nous pensions depuis le début que nous
devions mais suivre sur leur lire
travail mais nous nous sommes vite
aperçus que la télé appartenait plutôt à
l'univers familial pour examen
j'achetais le journal les a écouté la
radio mais les informations visuelles
meilleur ça les informations sont
indécis n'ont pas eu je suis pas un fan
athée c'est pas tout arrêter si un truc
c'est que j'ai acheté un marteau scop
des trois semaines et que je pouvais me
servir
à venger passant pas contenue à la télé
c'est un peu comme une fenêtre
par laquelle tout extériorise bon c'est
comme si tu as ta faim il ne fait qu'y
plus la télé qui est mûr a pas de la
télé tu te dis merde qu'est ce que je
fais entre quatre murs bon allez je sors
et je suis toujours dehors en fait
ouais
partout nous allons maintenant nous
croisons des gens qui ont des choses à
nous raconter on a deux enfants qui sont
toutes petites elles mêmes dans les deux
ans c'est vrai que c'est vachement
boulot qu'on arrête paul et que s'il y
en a un qui perd trois heures comme un
légume à regarder mais qui tapent dans
un ballon à l'autre pendant ce temps là
ils repassent il essuie la bouche avec
chances des couches enfin bon soir et
c'est toujours les mêmes qui le fait en
général parce que moi le football ce
n'est pas ça et comme les émissions qui
m'intéresse c'est le soir ou tard le
soir les enfants sont couchés et mon
mari lui peut lire tranquillement dans
un coin un circuit sa place à lui a
manqué beaucoup la télé les week-ends
pour malabo furent pas se faire non mais
je veux dire c'est vrai que ça lui a
manqué
plus élevé oui beaucoup oui non on a
passé des soirées entières oui la
repasser mon jacuzzi
il a passé l'aspirateur gg la poussière
on a fait un truc ensemble alors moi je
tricotais devant la télé mais l'enjeu
ses codes plus fait de la compta c'est
tout à fait passionnant les changes mais
en tout cas je m'étais dit que si
lorsque tout le reste est définie elle n
était pas accrocher des images qui sont
pas toujours choisi elles viendront
rejoindre plutôt lit ce serait plus
agréable que de m'endormir sur un
fauteuil en attendant en vain
voilà enfin cet email c'était une
espérance et vous avez eu de gros
problèmes avec votre fils c'est ça
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement
elle lui il s'est retrouvé à mercredi
après midi
sans télé et c'était le drame en fait
l'expérience a dû commencer à vendredi
week-end c'est à peu près bien passé
tout tournait jusqu'à mercredi à 2h
fatal où il s'est rendu compte que
c'était l'heure des émissions pour
enfants il n'avait pas du tout réagi
quelques jours auparavant que ben ça ça
sent très comblerait et il n'a pas du
tout apprécié une expérience qui nous
plaît pas
allergiques au mot très violemment
disons moi cette télé je vais la
retourne la chercher ils seront bien
obligés de me la donner il n'ya enfin
beau très violent
l'estonie apam lcd j'en ai marre je la
télé
et appelons un
chat avant 8 ans tu pouvais parce que
j'en ai pas cru
n'y voyez
comment est ce que tu es ce que tu
voudrais qu'on reprenne ma télé gino on
est bien comme ça alors tu es déçu toi
tu me dis ça ce voit ce que tu aimerais
qu elle dit oui côté moyens de descendre
avec elle a cherché
ouais mais en fait ils vont descendre à
laquelle va chercher les
choses ah ouais vous de venir chercher
le mercredi puis tu me ramènerait là je
dis
[Musique]
depuis le début de l'expérience
marie-christine joie redoutent la sortie
de l'école elle doit désormais affronter
seule ses enfants sans le secours de la
télé au riz etc alors maintenant vous
allez jouer tranquillement
[Musique]
oui sont tout à fait partie avec leur
poussent leur latin leur coussin le
petit hamel s'est joué auprès des grands
jours dont il vient de temps en temps
disons que c'est pas multiplié par trois
le petit vient mais les deux autres
bombes à et puis non je suis je suis
plus tranquille je sais que je peux
faire un plat
sans avoir tous concernés ont dérangé
sinon sans télévision bon c'est bien
mais suit y est je monte sur l'étagère
je casse tout je me bagarre je me cogne
donc ma braguette toulon pyjama bon
disons que ce moment là j'ai rarement
c'est la télévision je sais que j'ai à
peu près
20 minutes une demi heure ça me serais
fait largement
[Musique]
ces femmes tu veux pas m'apporter le des
petits jouets de guillaumin
pourquoi tu peux pas parce que quoi
apportant un petit truc demande à julien
était là guillaume importante du jeu
pour grégory
[Musique]
la télévision était dans la chambre
pourquoi dans la chambre parce qu'on se
sent on est plus proche et puis je crois
que me regarder la télévision pendant
une heure et demie si on regarde le film
assez à l'aube où bon nous le canapé
c'est pour un autre endroit moi je
n'apprécie pas je veux dire à la limite
j'ai l'impression de ne même pas rire
avec mon mari sa vie à lutter
parfois oui parfois oui à ce moment là
j'ai l'impression qu'on est bon dans
l'intimité on est dans notre champ est
on est on est ensemble ce que sans
télévision vous vous êtes un peu
redécouvert
lâché
non ça pas été là qu'on se bagarre mais
disons qu'on a dû remettre les choses
alors place
et je lui ai dit que finalement la
télévision pouvait être la suppression
de télévision pouvait être très bon
moyen pour quoi on dise plus ou qu'on
raconte plus qu'on fasse des enfants et
que moi je pensais que ça allait être un
long temps et finalement ça ne se
faisait pas
marc dubernet du galmudug
afrique de galles
mohamed ahmed
ouyahia au billabong mundo
morales à domenech a rappelé
mme danièle jilet une vilaine to
gaza
alors comment comment c'était votre vie
là bas
j'avais une vie extraordinaire mais
et je voulais aller voir autre chose et
ce qui existe déjà vous avez des marges
et le conte oui j'étais marié raison
pour laquelle j'ai mes deux enfants et
puis mais revenons chez libre c'est que
vous avez accepté de faire l'expérience
de vieux os en la télévision alors
pourquoi est-ce que vous cherchiez
véritablement moi je travaille toute la
journée des enfants passe l'air passe
toute la journée à l'école on accueille
dimanche parce que je travaille le
samedi je travaille l'animateur
accueille dimanche bon dimanche je suis
très fatigué je dois y aller jusqu'à 11
heures midi j'aimerais avait ya et stark
et après ça qui a maille après maille à
et à tout le monde il faut manger un
petit bout carte hommage et bien huit
ans il fallait oui parce que donner des
enfants clan et je me suis rendu compte
que la télé prend beaucoup de temps
parce que personnellement j'ai pas c'est
un miracle et prend le pouls de tard que
j'ai avec mes enfants et là je pouvais
là je pouvais je vous préviens de
matinée encore parce que je vivrai mal
africaine et ça me manquait beaucoup
mais j'avoue que je connaissais pas un
an toutes les têtes et je le connaissais
pas parce que bon bin
essa je prie que la télé est vraiment
une bonne partie responsables que vous
avez découvert printemps le personnalité
les idées comment y penser tout haut
1 comment y pense et puis le
raisonnement donc épi l'amour l'amour
que les enfants étaient mes enfants pour
tous beaucoup avec moi bon j'ai jamais
fait attention je pense étaient des
enfants pour moi c'est des enfants tout
le temps mais le raisonnement est tout
parce que bon un creux 7h et 8h je peux
dire que c'est long parce qu'il n'a pas
la télé et puis les enfants sur itunes
repose en cause mais j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses vous avez l'air de
dire que telle fusion coupe le contact
avait beaucoup ça je pourrais toutes mes
responsabilités je le dis en
s'accouplant ya pas passer de
communication et je pense que les jeux
en france souffre beaucoup de 550
content parce que je pense que les
personnes soient pour marier avec la
technique avec leurs maillots le femme
en question parce que à la télé
j'entends des scènes de ménage à cause
de la télé mais quand on vraiment quand
on s'aime latrines tout parent ne peut
pas séparer de chair qui sait
[Musique]